مرحبا بكم من جديد الرئيس الفرنسي في
مقابله تلفزيونيه جدد التزامه باصلاح نظام
التقاعد رغم احتجاجات النقابات وحذر ان
السلطات لن تسمح بتكرار الاحداث التي وقعت
مؤخرا خلال المظاهرات في العاصمه وبقيه
المحافظات تلك التصريحات جلبت المزيد من
الغضب مع كثير من التحدي لدى المحتجين مع
مواصله التظاهرات بالارتكاز على دعوه
النقابات الى اضراب عام في يوم وصفه
الاعلام الفرنسي بالخميس الاسود
بالمقابل اتخذت السلطات تحسبا لموجه تاسعه
من الاحتجاجات تدبر امنيه اضافيه وخصص
وزير الداخليه جرار درمنا خمسه الاف من
رجال الشرطه لاداء مهامهم في العاصمه وطلب
ديرمنان جهات انفاذ القانون بتجاهل
الاستفزازات المحتمله التي يمكن ان يقوم
بها اليسار المتطرف وفق قوله ويتوقع جهاز
الاستخبارات الاقليميه التابعه لمديريه
الشرطه مشاركه نحو 600 عنصر متطرف بمن
فيهم من حركه السترات السفر بحسب قوله كما
اوصت السلطات المطارات
المطارات الفرنسيه طبعا الركاب باعاده
جدوله ايام سفرهم الجوي وخفضت المديريه
العامه للطيران المدني الفرنسي عدد
الرحلات من مطارات ليون مارسيليا وتولوز
بنسبه 20%
[موسيقى]
نناقش هالموضوع من باريس مع وليد عباس
الكاتب الصحافي ومن باريس ايضا طارق وهبي
المحلل السياسي مرحبا بكم ضيفيه الكريمين
ابدا معك استاذ وليد عباس حتى الان في
مظاهرات ما اصطلح على تسميته اعلاميا
بالخميس الاسود في فرنسا من تراه الاقوى
النقابات والمحتجون ام الرئيس ماكرون
يعني هو السؤال من تراه الاقوى الشارع
الفرنسي عموما ام الرئيس ماكرون الذي يقف
عمليا بمفرده امام هذه الموجه والموجات
المختلفه ومنها الموجه التاسعه اليوم
النقابات اعلنت انه يوجد في باريس وحدها
حوالي 800 الف متظاهر هناك بعض احداث
الشغب التي وقعت على هامش المظاهره في
شوارع موازيه للمظاهره قامت بها عناصر من
البلاك بلوك ومن اليسار المتطرف والسترات
الصفراء ولكن المظاهره في حد ذاتها اتخذت
مسارها في اطار التنظيم الذي تفرضه
النقابات على مصر في مثل هذه المناسبات
اليوم الرئيس ماكرون كان ينتظره على ما
اعتقد بعد حديث الذي اذن به بالامس ليرى
مدى حجم الحشد الذي
سينزل الى الشوارع يبدو ان النقابات وفقت
الى حد بعيد لان الحشد اليوم يتجاوز
الايام الاخيره من المشابهه
وضربوا ارقام قياسيه اليوم في حشد اعداد
من المتظاهرين سواء في العاصمه او في
المدن الكبرى والمتوسطه وحتى الصغيره نعم
طيب
كذلك اسالك سيد طارق وهبي الرئيس ماكرون
في خرجته التلفزيونيه بالامس بدا واثقا
مما يفعل هو قال انه صحيح انه قانون اصلاح
التقاعد في فرنسا ورفع سن التقاعد من 62
الى 64 عاما لا يعجبه شخصيا ولكن هذا
للمصلحه الوطنيه وهو يدرك ان شعبيته في
انخفاض بسبب هذا الاصلاح ولكنه مصر عليه
هل تراه سيغير موقفه بعد هذه الاعداد
الغفيره التي خرجت في المناطق الفرنسيه
العده اليوم في الخميس الاسود
مساء الخير يا سيدي شكرا للاستضافه ورمضان
كريم
تحيه لضيفك العزيز الصديق وليد عباس سيد
العزيز الرئيس مكروه هو رئيس يعني
بالفرنسيه
بمعنى دائما هو لديه مسرين متوازيين بمعنى
هو يرى ان ما قاله البارحه هو مهم
بالمفهوم القانوني وهو مهم ايضا بالمفهوم
الدستوري
على على المستويين وايضا هو يقول ان ضروره
هذه
يعني هذا القانون او هذا الاصلاح يبدا
بما قاله هو بمعنى انهم لم يستطيعوا ان
يفسروا او ان يعطوا تفسيرات مهمه لكل
المواطنين الفرنسيين ليصلوا الى ما نسميه
نوعا من بين قوسين وقف لكل ما يحدث في
الشارع حاليا لذلك انا برايي الشارع لا
يزال مستنفر الشارع اكثر من اعتبر ان بعض
المقاطع التي قالها الرئيس ماكرون البارحه
انه استفزه لاقصى حد وانا برايي مشكله
رئيس ماكرون للاسف الشديد انه يستعمل بعض
المصطلحات التي ترجع الى ما نسميه نوع من
الرفض التام للفرنسيين في التغيير وهو
الرئيس الذي يقول ان علينا ان نكون بما
نسميه مسره جديد مصرى تغيير لان ان لم نكن
في هذه المسرح فرنسا ستكون يعني باخر
الدول الاوروبيه وهذا ما قاله في الجزء
الثاني من مقابلته وعندما ركز على موضوع
ان علينا الان ان نطوي صفحه وان نبدا بما
نسميه الحديث حول قانون العمل وكيفيه
توافق قانون العمل مع هذا القانون ضد على
ذلك اعطى مهمه كبيره لرئيسه الحكومه لكي
تنفتح على يعني الاطراف السياسيين يمينا
ويسارا ولكن انا برايي حتى اللحظه وعندما
نرى يعني الجماهير التي كانت في
المظاهرات ليس باعتقادي ان ذلك ممكنا حتى
اللحظه طيب استاذ وليد عباس ما رايك هل
ستطوى الصفحه كما قال الاستاذ طارق وهبي
صفحه قانون التقاعد في فرنسا ام نحن
مقبلون على فوضى اكبر هناك
يعني تحيه للاستاذ طارق اولا لا اعتقد
نهائيا ان صفحه ستطوى نحن امام مواجهه
طويله الامد نحن وصلنا الى وضع مغلق طريق
مسدود عمليا لان رئيس ماكرون في حديثي
بالامس كرر لاته ثلاثه اي لا لسحب القانون
لا لتعديل وزاري ولا للاستفتاء حول هذا
القانون يعني قد استعير عباره او وصف قاله
احد النقابيين عندما قال شعرنا اننا امام
موظف بنك يشرح لنا خطه للتوفير بمعنى ان
مشكله الرئيس مكروه انه تحدث بالامس في
اطار القواعد
والقوانين ولكن لم يتحدث كسياسي هو رئيس
يحكم بلد باكمله ولم يتحدث سياسي نحن امام
بلد لم تعد المشكله فقط قانون التقاعد
لانه منذ ان استخدمت الحكومه المدى
التاسعه والاربعين ثلاثه شاهد ان اعداد
المتظاهرين من الشباب ارتفعت بشكل كبير
لان هؤلاء الشباب ربما في البدايه كانوا
يرون ان قضيه التقاعد بعيده عنهم بعض
الشيء ولكنهم الان ينزلون الى الشارع
لانهم يخافون على النظام الديمقراطي رئيس
ماكرون اليوم الراي العام ضده نصف
استفتاءات واستطلاعات الراي الحركه
النقابيه تمكن الرئيس ماكرون من توحيدها
للمره الاولى ضده واخيرا حتى النواب
البرلمان لم يحصل على اغلبيه لديهم استاذ
طارق وهبي في ضوء هذا المشهد وهذا الوضع
لماكرون
هناك محاولات
لطرح الثقه من الحكومه الفرنسيه ان كان من
حزب مارين لوبان وهناك تحرك اخر كذلك هل
تعتقد ان الحكومه الفرنسيه ستصمد ام لا
سيكون هناك تغيير جذري هذه المره او
نزال سياسي يكون في خضم فوضى في الشارع
مستمره لفتره طويله
يعني
الثقه على الحكومه الفرنسيه خسر في
البرلمان الفرنسي على تسعه اصوات عندما
تقدمت كتله وسطيه وليست كتله يعني فيها اي
اشمئزاز سياسي بالمفهوم السياسي بمعنى ان
كتله السيده عندما تقدمت بطرح الثقه لم
تحصل على اكثر من 94 صوتا بينما الكتله
الوسطيه التي تقدمت
بطرح الثقه يعني خسرت
رهانها على سبعه اصوات وهذا ينذر للرئيس
ماكرون بالقول انه صحيح قد تعتبر ان خساره
يعني عدم يعني طرح الثقه لم يعطيك لم تربح
ولكن بنفس الوقت لا يستطيع ان يقال انه
مرر القانون في هذا الموضوع ما قاله
الاستاذ وليد كتير مهم ان هناك طبقه جديده
من الذين يتظاهرون وهذه الطبقه هي طبقه
الشباب هذه الطبقه شباب اقفلت سبع جامعات
في
في باريس الكبرى يعني هناك سبع جامعات
مقفله الان في باريس الكبرى هناك ايضا
طلاب من السنويات يتظاهرون وهذا يقطع ايضا
بشحن في الشارع وقد يعني الشارع قد يفلت
باي وقت وخصوصا ان راينا منذ اربعه ايام
في باريس هناك هناك يعني نوع من نيران
تحترق يعني هناك يعني شوارع تحترق وخصوصا
ان هناك ازمه كبيره لها علاقه
بالقمامه داخل باريس زد على ذلك يا سيدي
ان الحل الان
يعني لا يمكن ان يقبل الرئيس ماكرون كما
قال الاستاذ وليد يعني تغيير رئيس الحكومه
طرح استفتاء شعبي او حتى الغاء القانون هو
يريد ان يكمل في هذا الموضوع ولكن كيف
يستطيع ان يكمل انا برايي
الهدف الرئيسي هو انشاء ما نسميه ائتلاف
سياسي يعني الغزل السياسي باتجاه اليمين
التقليدي اي الجمهوريين ووضع هؤلاء
الجمهوريين جميل ما يسمى نوع من ائتلاف
يصل به الى
اغلب البرلمان يستطيع ان يكمل فيها
السنوات الاربعه
التي اريد ان اسال فيها نعم هذه نقطه مهمه
جدا استاذ طارق وهبي استاذ وليد عباس
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون جاء من خارج
المنظومه التقليديه في السياسه الفرنسيه
عندما ربح في الانتخابات هو جاء النخب
الفرنسي عاقب اليسار التقليدي واليمين
التقليدي وانتخب ماكرون لانه خارج هذه
المنظومه ولفتني في كلامك عندما نقلا عما
وصف الرئيس في خطابي في كلمته يعني في
مقابلته بانه موظف بنك يشرح لنا خطه توفير
ما الفرنسيون هم اختاروا هذا الشخص لانه
ات من خارج المنظومه السياسيه الفرنسيه
التقليديه الان ما الحل
يعني الفرنسيون اختاروا مطمور لانه مجربه
اليسار وجربوا اليمين وكانوا يرون انهم
يطبقون ذات السياسه التي لم تعجبهم
وبالتالي عندما ظهر ماكرون فهو كان وجه
جديد يقول انه يستخدم عباره في نفس الوقت
يمكنني ان اطبق شيئين قد يبدو
متناقضين في نفس الوقت
فبالتالي اعجبت الفكره الفرنسيين ولكن في
نهايه الامر
شاهدنا في مرحله الرئاسيه الاولى ثوره
السفره التي التي كانت حركه عنيفه للغايه
وادت الى الى تجميد ماكرون خلال الفتره
الرئاسيه الاولى في الفتره الرئاسيه
الثانيه عادوا انتخابرا نتمكن من ان يضع
نفسه امام مارين لوبين في الدوره الثانيه
والخيار كان صعب امام الفرنسيين ان
يختاروا مارين لوبينغ عن ويفضلوها عن
ماكرون مما فيه انه ياتي يعني يجب الا
ننسى ان مكروه ياتي بالفعل من الاوساط
الماليه ورجل كان يعمل في بنك بنك قبل ذلك
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك هذه العقليه هل
يعود الفرنسيون الان جربوا شخصيه خارج
المنظومه التقليديه السياسيه هل يعودون
الان مثلا لليمين لليسار لاقصى اليمين هل
يعني الان لديها حظوظ اكبر في الانتخابات
المقبله ام ماذا
مما لا شك ان لديها حظوظ كبيره في
الانتخابات المقبله ولكن الانتخابات
المقبله ما زالت بعيده ما زال امامنا اربع
سنوات مؤكده ان ماكرون لن لا يستطيع ان
يتقدم للترشح لمره شرسه انتهى
والمشكله ايضا انه لم تبرز حتى الان شخصيه
بارزه وقويه شخصيه سياسيه بارزه وقويه
باستثناء نوعا من نوعا ما يسارا ولكن في
اليمين التقليدي لم تظهر شخصيه قويه
تستطيع ان تسلط نفسها اليسار يعتبر يعني
يعتبر
وقت انتهى ولكن لابد ان اخذ رايك في هذه
النقطه تحديدا لكي اختم بها باختصار شديد
ماكرون خارج المنظومه اليمين واليسار
الفرنسيه التقليديه واهاهم الفرنسيون
ينتفضون عليه بسبب قانون التقاعد ما سيكون
مصيره
انا باعتقادي سيكمل العهده الثانيه الرئيس
ماكرون ولكن كما قلت لك هو يبحث عن ائتلاف
سياسي وهذا الائتلاف سياسي قد يذهب به الى
الى الى طلب بعض من الخضر يعني حزب الخضر
وقد يكون مشروعه بمفهوم البيئه يعني لانه
عندما تسمع المقابله البارحة وركز على
موضوع استعاده فرنسا لما تسميه السياده
الصناعيه والسياده الصناعيه التي تتاقلم
مع المفهوم البيئي وانا برايي هو سيستطيع
ان يجمع لانه حتى اللحظه حتى اللحظه لا
يزال يعني يسمع في الاوساط السياسيه ما
يقوله الرئيس مكروه شكرا جزيلا لك طارق
وهبي انت المحلل السياسي
والشكر لك ايضا وليد عباس الكاتب الصحفي
كنتما معنا من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
بانوراما مستمره بعد الفاصل
اهه مصير تيك توك البيع ام الحظر وهل ينجح
رئيس التطبيق الصيني في انقاذه خلال جلسته
امام الكونجرس
[موسيقى]